[موسيقى]
اسبوع هو الاطول على روسيا ربما منذ بدات
حملتها العسكريه في اوكرانيا في فبراير من
العام الماضي اسبوع تغير فيه اتجاه
الهجمات من الغرب الى الشرق اخر هذه
الهجمات ما اعلنه حاكم منطقه بيسكوف
الروسيه عن هجوم بمسييرتين ملاغمتين
استهدف محطه لتكرير النفط تمد خط دركبه
ضخم الذي ينقل النفط الخامه من سيبيريا
نحو اوروبا الهجوم الذي اوقع اضرارا في
ثلاثه مباني اداريه في المحطه وقع حسب
الروايه الروسيه في منطقه مثلث الحدود بين
روسيا وبيلاروسيا ولاتفيا وتبعد مسافه 600
كيلومتر عن الحدود مع اوكرانيا وتلك مسافه
بعيده لكن بالقرب من الحدود مع اوكرانيا
تحدثت المصادر الروسيه عن قصف المدفعي
الاوكراني طالم مقاطعه الروسيه في خامس
هجوم تتهم موسكو كييف بالمسؤوليه عنه خلال
اقل من اسبوع تصير السلطات الاوكرانيه على
التاكيد ان ما يجري وفي عموم التراب
الروسي شان داخلي وتنفي اي علاقه لها بما
يجري من جهتها تمضي وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
في اتهام اوكرانيا حيث اعلنت انها اعترضت
صاروخين من طراز كروز بعيد المدى من طراز
ستورم شادو التي كانت بريطانيا قد قدمته
لاوكرانيا وفي الخامس والعشرين من هذا
الشهر اتهم جهاز امن الدوله الروسي من
وصفه بالمخربين الاوكرانيين بمحاوله تخريب
محطتين نوويتين في الانجراد غرب البلاد
استهداف المحطتين النوويتين جاء بعد اقل
من يوم واحد على تعرض السفينه الحربيه
الروسيه ايفانخورس لما قالت موسكو انه
هجوم الفاشل من ثلاثه زوارق مسيره
الاوكرانيه في البحر الاسود بالقرب من
مضيق الفوسفور وهو ما اعلنت كييف لاحقا
المسؤوليه عنه
سبق ذلك بيوم واحد هجوم مجموعات عسكريه
اوكرانيه ذات توجه قومي كما وصفته موسكو
على مقاطعه بلغرود باستخدام معدات عسكريه
غربيه الصنع بينما قال ما يسمى بفيلق
المتطوعين الروس انه نفذ عمليه ناجحه في
المنطقه ورغم غموض التصريحات الاوكرانيه
بشان عدد من هذه الهجمات خصوصا ما اذا
كانت تندرج في اطار هجومها المضاد الذي
تقول احيانا انه بدا واحيانا اخرى انه شيك
فان الحرب بين الطرفين كما تبدو من بعيد
قد دخلت مرحله جديده مع تطلع اوكرانيا
للحصول على طائرات اف 16 وحديث برلين عن
تلقيها طلبا من الكيف للحصول على صواريخ
كروز تطلق من الجو ويبلغ مداها 500
كيلومتر